là maintenant oui
on regarde on regarde et puis bon ben on
met plus spécialement certains produits
dans notre caddie et des fois voir
carrément pas
[Musique]
j'ai ajouté les prix de magasin que j'ai
fait et que j'ai vu qu'il y avait une
différence de prix sur la même quantité
sur la même marque vraiment sur le la
même chose c'est pas c'est pas c'est
comparer sur la même chose voilà donc
j'ai marqué les prix qui qui me servent
bien et qui nous permet de faire nos
courses un petit peu au pieuvre dans
chaque magasin
[Musique]
c'est un changement de consommation qui
est très important puisque en fait nos
clients ils ont besoin de deux choses la
première c'est de tenir au mieux le
budget alimentaire qu'ils ont de
disponible chaque mois et puis la
deuxième chose c'est de ne rien renier à
la qualité alimentaire des produits
qu'ils achètent et c'est la raison pour
laquelle depuis maintenant plusieurs
mois nous sommes aux côtés de nos
clients avec un certain nombre de
propositions anti-inflation on a appelé
les défis anti-inflation pour répondre à
ce besoin très important de nos clients
de soutenir leur pouvoir d'achat
[Musique]